[Musique]
kassim brouillet vous accueillez dans
votre jardin secret compris progressive
et rui commençaient les gens parlent de
havre de paix c'est pas tout à fait ce
il est possible qu'on entende la cie et
camions passent et on est à montréal bon
c'est comme ça
mais oui quand c'est quand même je me
permets d'écrire l'été dans mon jardin
ou dans la chaise ou en fait j'en
profite
c'est comme une pièce de plus dans la
maison et j'entends les oiseaux et moi
parce que sur la table qui est juste à
ma droite c'est votre tableau de travail
la table des travaux mais j'ai vu des
plats oui vous trouvez toujours le
complot je serai toujours avec un plan
il arrive que je dévie du chemin que je
me suis tracé souvent j'ai des mauvaises
surprises quand je fais ça je tiens ce
serait mieux qu'après si je l'avais fait
comme tous les gamins de logique et des
fois je suis tentée de bon de faire le
plein du saunier mais en général j'ai de
toute façon pour un roman policier moi
j'ai besoin de savoir comment ça se
termine
moi j'ai besoin je suis courageux
d'angoissé j'ai besoin de savoir où je
m'en vais s'ils corrigent ou d'angoissé
ça veut dire que j'essaie de tout
contrôler alors je peux vous dire que
les dernières semaines on était
interdite ouais pour la sortie du
nouveau les mêmes pour tous
tout était compliqué quand il peut pas
quand c'est la planète au complet qui
sans contrôle convient dans le chaos
total et absolut
ok ce qu'on fait on s'abandonne avec
toute l'expérience le temps qui passe
vous avez dit que le syndrome de la page
blanche s'accentue oui vous avez
toujours un bon bassin de lecteurs
comment vous vivez avec cette pression
de livre en livre de faux-pas
dispenseront mais vous avez la pression
et j'ai de la pression que je me mets
moi même parce que je me dis
je vais pas décevoir mais assez de c'est
très paradoxal en même temps j'ai plus
de pression je ne veux pas décevoir
puis en même temps j'arrive maintenant
d'autres dents quand j'ai fait les
cibles quand je suis arrivé à la moitié
c'était la catastrophe
j'étais vraiment dix jours sans rien
écrire la panique totale je me dis mais
j'en sortirai jamais je ne sortirais
jamais pu pourtant j'avais un plan mais
le clame paraissait plus bon notre
cobras f2 rien calais puis le tout à
coup je me suis vraiment parler je me
suis dit christine temps quand même 37
ans de métier il faut que ça serve à
quelque chose
il ya une solution quelque part
calme-toi essaie d'avancer bon et c'est
ce qui je suis beaucoup et où jean marc
et l'esprit bon j'ai fini par dépasser
la la page 150 mais c'est fragile la
création c'est fragile pour moi en tout
cas il ya des gens qui écrivent dans la
joie l'allégresse je les envie ça
m'étonne vraiment que vous me disais que
ça vous a angoissé que vous prenait pas
de plaisir à écrire voilà il ya
tellement de choses j'en ris parce qu'il
faut faire c'est de pouvoir ça dans
l'autodérision moi quand j'écris je suis
dans le doute absolu la page et c'est
ardu je n'ai pas de plaisir à écrire sur
ce intéressant mais du plaisir j'ai du
plaisir à recevoir des amis à préparer
des repas des choses que j'ai pas besoin
de me concentrer ou je suis dans
l'abandon quand j'écris je suis tout ce
dont l'abandon donc c'est intéressant
mais plaisant quand même stimulant avec
une bonne idée d'avoir bien réussi à
trouver un filon est bon mais ses fruits
c'est très fugace dire que je me lève le
matin je m'en veux écrire non non c'est
un travail pcc a retenu puis j'aime ce
travail je me sens privilégié de
l'exercer et puis d'en vivre c'est
vraiment
grande grande grande chance j'ai des
lecteurs fidèles de plus de 30 ans c'est
un vrai cadeau mais ça serait mentir de
dire j'ai du plaisir non non j'ai du
plaisir dans un souper quand j'ai les
amis réunis quand on cache sent le
parfum de 2000 plants de tomates qui
s'en vient bien oui ceci plaisant mais
pauvre popaul non plus donc lorsque vous
marchez ici pour vous en venir à votre
poste de travail sacs easybag abandon je
me demande qu'est ce qu'il faut pas que
j'oublie pire c'est jacques fait si mélo
johnston avec deryck et peu près à mon
dieu j'essaie de tout contrôler de tous
pensé c'est non j'ai pas dans le plaisir
justement pour votre nouveau livre qui
est la dix neuvième enquête de mots g
vous êtes vraiment intéressé à
l'homophobie au crime haineux quand vous
avez choisi ce thème là spécifiquement
parce que j'en ai marre que ça existe
encore ça me met en colère je trouve ça
désespérant qu'en 2020 je crois qu'il en
soit 110 pays où l'homosexualité est
n'est pas toléré une quinzaine de pays
où elle est passible de peine de mort je
trouve ce dynamisme est un mot beaucoup
trop faible c'est incroyable et ça doit
changer chez choses là moi je m'inquiète
pour des amis simplement parce qu'ils
préfèrent les hommes où ils préfèrent
les femmes ça ne doit pas être comme ça
alors moi je me suis dit j'en parle je
serais si je fais changer une personne
d'avis sur la situation je vais être
très heureuse
on aurait pu faire 30 minutes avec le
symbole c'était absolument fascinant
merci beaucoup c'est un grand plaisir
merci beaucoup de m'avoir invité